le niveau des professeurs a-t-il
vraiment baissé comment faire confiance
à quelqu'un qui écrit sans Siller il a
poussé un élève pour enseigner la
grammaire à mes enfants c'est en tout
cas la vie de certains parents d'élèves
comme cette maman qui s'en est pleain
sur les réseaux sociaux en novembre et
il suffit de jeter un œil au
compte-rendu des juris au concours du
CAPS et du CAFEP de lettrre classiqu et
modne il pointe les fragilités de
nombreux candidats une expression pauvre
et un maigre bagage littéraire
artistique et historique les correcteurs
des copies rapportent aussi de
nombreuses erreurs d'orthographe de
conjugaison et de grammaire notamment
sur l'accord du participe passé avec
l'auxiliaire avoir quand le COD est
placé avant le verbe berenis par exemple
est jeune professeur de français dans un
collège et elle l'avoue sans complexe
elle fait souvent des fautos tableau
parfois les élèves nous font la remarque
on voit qu'ils suivent il est important
de se corriger devant eux d'ancien
professeurs de français m'ont dit qu'ils
ont des problèmes avec des règles
d'orthographe et nous déculpabilisent
beaucoup là-dessus pareil pour François
agrégé de lettres et professeur de
français dans un collège qui a vous
faire des fautes par manque de vigilance
et par usage de l'ordinateur lui qui en
était assez honteux pour Olivier godet
prof de lettre à versaill c'est que les
concours sont moins exigeants
qu'autrefois statistiquement comme il y
a moins de monde au concours la barre
est plus basse et donc la sélection
moins exigeante qu'on se rassure les
candidats qui présentaient une
orthographe vraiment défaillante
n'obtiennent pas de note au-dessus de la
note éliminatoire 5/ 20 en attendant le
ministère recrute de plus en plus à la
dernière minute des contractuels qui
n'ont qu'une licence bac+ 3 et ne sont
pas toujours bien formmer comme le
métier a une image qui se dégrade et
qu'il y a de moins en moins de gens qui
ont envie de l'exercer l'institution
recr qui elle peut et cela ne facilite
pas forcément une amélioration de
l'image du métier explique jeanry Gérard
président d'un syndicat de professeur le
7 décembre les inscriptions au concours
d'enseignant 2024 se sont clôturé alors
même que le classement PISA a révélé que
la France se situait seulement à la 29e
place en niveau de compréhension écrite
des élèves
[Musique]
français